a proposal for an urban food truck plot
in downtown las vegas art district
is creating a divide between project
developers and local businesses
reporter kate houston breaking down how
developers want to transform that space
and also the changes that businesses
want to see before that plan moves
forward
project developers want to turn this
vacant area on south casino center and
california avenue
into a bustling food truck lot we want
to bring the culinary arts
to the arts district bringing 10 food
trucks not only 10 food trucks but 10
selective food trucks 10 of the top food
trucks here in las vegas
in december the planning commission
approved the proposal despite
staff recommending against it developers
say the variety of food trucks and open
air concept will help drive more people
into the area
but businesses are concerned about a
lack of sanitation
waste management and how it will look
it's negligent to
the overall well-being and welfare for
not just
the the look of the arts district the
feel of the arts district but
for the well-being of the surrounding
businesses mario enriquez with garagist
which is next to the vacant lot
says the arts district wants to welcome
more small businesses but there needs to
be consistency
holding everybody to the same standards
is what we are all concerned with
and for good reason everybody should be
held to the same standards in order to
promote any given neighborhood or area
project managers say the next steps are
to ensure
everything is in compliance noel
casemiro with great american foodie fest
says he understands the concerns and
they're working to address them
we're going to do our best to create a
win-win situation where everyone is
happy and pleased
and that this food truck concept park
that's going to be in this area is going
to benefit
everyone there instead of impact them in
a negative way
kate houston 8 news now now due to the
pushback from some of those local
businesses there councilwoman olivia
diaz requested the proposal be discussed
before city council and that meeting
will happen we're told now in early
march